a new promo drop for bachelor in
paradise season six and aside from the
tears a brawl on the beach and Dean with
a weird mustache people can't stop
talking about demi Burnett fan favorite
from Colton Underwood season kissing
another woman I don't care who see this
I know that I love this girl I'm just so
happy that I found her and I can
definitely picture being with her for
the rest of my life so there's no
official word on who the mystery woman
is but it seems like Demi has some
serious feelings for her could this be
the franchise's first same-sex
relationship demi took to twitter
shortly after the new trailer dropped to
send a message about her sexuality
spoiler alert I'm a queer Queen her
tweet was met with praise from bachelor
nation and fellow bachelor alum Kalyn
Miller Keys who tweeted you are an
absolute Queen and I love you so freakin
much and current Bachelorette Hannah
Brown responded with and we all bow down
I love you always and forever but this
wouldn't be bachelor in paradise with
had some drama right from what we can
tell from the promo it seems like
dummies in a love triangle with Derek
and the mystery woman last night I mean
I had a really
I'm in the hot tub
that's not something I should have to
hide
now we've seen same-sex couples on other
bachelor style shows around the world
remember back in 2016 when two
contestants from Australia's version of
The Bachelor
Megan Marx and Tiffany Scanlon fell in
love with each other and what about that
intense moment when two women confess
their love for each other on The
Bachelor Vietnam anything in a human no
hope for I laugh
[Music]
I'm okay
yeah yeah yeah so a big question on the
minds of bachelor nation is will demigod
will she get engaged to the mystery
woman I smell an engagement and it fills
the meeting are you excited for Demi in
her quest to find love on the new season
of bachelor in paradise how do you feel
about The Bachelor franchise putting the
spotlight on a queer relationship let me
know in the comments below
you